you know whoever God has for me and
that's him well he's here cuz Sadie
Robertson is a married woman y'all the
duck dynasty star and former Dancing
with the Stars finalist said I do to
Christian Hough on Monday and according
to multiple reports the ceremony went
down at her parents property in West
Monroe Louisiana it's just been really
special on Monday the 22 year old shared
this pic on Instagram smiling ear-to-ear
in head-to-toe white with the caption
feeling like I'm about to be a wifey and
I'm pretty happy about it
and the Bible is a very clear thing and
13 about what love is it his patient and
his kind and it goes through this whole
thing over the weekend she posted this
pic of her all up in her man's personal
space writing so close to forever and
then there's this shot of the happy
couple posing it up with their marriage
license and a mustache sorry it's just
hard not to notice the mustache anyway
Sadie captioned the pic this chapter of
life is called marriage license and a
mustache and I couldn't be happier about
it the wedding comes nearly six months
after Sadie revealed that she and
Christian were engaged back in June she
shared this video of the sweet proposal
on Instagram writing in part I am the
happiest human in the world today and
for the rest of my life I get to marry
this man
[Music]
and while sadie is officially living out
her happily ever after now back in 2017
then single Sadie told et what she was
looking for in a man I'm looking for
somebody who really just loves the
person I am and not who I am in the
public which is the same it's the same
person but it's different I don't want
something that's just post on Instagram
whenever something also happens I want
somebody who like calls when I know
maybe in like yeah I can literally show
up at their house which is like my
typical but on top of that no makeup
sweat pants sweatshirt that's what I
want I want somebody I can just go play
tennis with because this life is so not
normal that I'm living right now I want
somebody I can just be normal with your
brother and your sister have set such a
beautiful example with their marriages
does that it all give you the bug is
there pressure because your siblings are
married that you got to tie the knot you
know you used to it did totally because
my family many people in my family got
married at 18 or 19 okay
and so I hit 18 and I don't even have a
boyfriend I'm like well obviously I'm a
fan getting married at age came here
nothing and at the same time I was 18 19
my brother Joey coming my cousin Rita my
best friend Breton got married my sister
and John Reed got married I'm laughs oh
my gosh this is not good but then I like
took it like deep breath I was like okay
this is really good they're 18 and 19
I'm here so no pressure here and so yeah
no I'm so happy for them and if they
found that but I'm not in a rush if I
found that yes Congrats
Sadie here's to you and a lifetime full
of love okay of course you can count on
ET to keep you in the loop on all things
Sadie so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Holly
Stephens see you soon
[Music]